erreicht künstliche intelligenz jetzt
eine neue dimension spintronik chips auf
den prozessoren und speicher nicht mehr
getrennt sind sondern quasi miteinander
verwoben sind sind die neue
schlüsseltechnologie
das ergebnis wären viel schnellere
rechner die vor allem für künstliche
intelligenz ki erhebliche vorteile
hätten
dennoch benötigt eine menge an energie
und stößt bei herkömmlichen rechnern an
ihre grenzen klick substanzen future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los ganz herzlich willkommen
teilt dieses video wenn er meint dass
andere von diesem durchbruch erfahren
sollen welche unglaublichen fortschritte
heute elektronik noch machen kann hat
sich dieses jahr war apple gezeigt der
neue m1 chip verweist die konkurrenz von
einem auf den anderen tag auf die
hinteren plätze
und zwar was geschwindigkeit und was
besonders wichtig für mobiles arbeiten
ist was den energieverbrauch angeht
dafür hat der prozessor insgesamt 24
spezialisierte prozessorkerne an bord
also 24 einzelnen prozessoren
wir sind hochleistungs prozessoren vier
arbeiten möglichst energiesparend und 16
sind für künstliche intelligenz
optimiert und diese prozessorkerne und
der fünfundzwanzigste prozessor der
grafikprozessor greifen auf einen
einzigen speicher zu zahlreiche
informationen müssen nicht mehr auf
langen wegen durch den rechner geschickt
werden sie sind direkt da wo sie
gebraucht werden
bei den heutigen immer aufwendigeren
prozessoren in rechnern werden die wege
immer entscheidender denn umso länger
sie sind desto länger dauert es auch
etwas zu berechnen und desto mehr
energie wird auch verbraucht auch allen
masc wird die nächste batterie
generation genau darauf hin optimieren
überall an kathode und anode liegen dann
anschlüsse an und die elektronen müssen
nicht mehr quer durch die ganze batterie
die akkus können dann viel schneller mit
viel weniger lade verlusten geladen
werden auch hier wieder der vorteil
geschwindigkeit und energie ersparnis
beim schnellladen eines model 3 können
heute nämlich noch bis zu 25 prozent
lade verlust entstehen das ist erheblich
und auch eben bei prozessoren spielt der
energieverbrauch eine erhebliche rolle
und das insbesondere bei künstlicher
intelligenz ki denn hier muss das gehirn
quasi als algorithmus simuliert werden
und das kostet unmengen an energie
denn unser gehirn ist komplett anders
als moderne computer aufgebaut dort wird
die effizienz absolut auf die spitze
getrieben wir haben nämlich keinen
stromanschluss sondern müssen unsere
energie durch nahrung aufnehmen und die
muss auch noch erst in verwertbare
energie umgewandelt werden um das zu
leisten was unser gehirn leistet muss es
also extrem sparsam sein zum einen
arbeitet es dafür nicht sehr genau wir
müssen uns im gegensatz zu einem
computer schon sehr anstrengen um mal
eben 17,8 x 23,7 zu rechnen aber dafür
sind wir in dem was künstliche
intelligenz leisten kann extrem gut
gesichtserkennung sprache orientierung
wissenschaft und so weiter und so fort
unser gehirn ist eine absolute
hochleistungsmaschine und das bei sehr
geringen stromverbrauch und der treibt
die prozessor speicher effizienz noch
mal auf die spitze beide sind bei uns
nämlich nicht getrennt sondern
ineinander verwoben noch haben wir über
unser gehirn ein sehr beschränktes
wissen aber eines wissen wir unsere
prozessoren die neuronen und die
verbindung die synapsen liegen direkt
beieinander und können eben auch dort
informationen abspeichern spricht die
errechneten ergebnisse können direkt vor
ort gespeichert werden der weg ist
nahezu null
und auch unser langzeitgedächtnis indem
wir informationen ablegen quasi unsere
festplatte ist so in den prozessor
integriert sprich in unserem gehirn ist
eine moderne prozessorarchitektur auf
die spitze getrieben und das wollen
jetzt auch forschende erreichen sie
haben bereits sehr effiziente prototypen
gebaut die wie unser gehirn
funktionieren und so aufgaben der
künstlichen intelligenz deutlich
effizienter und energiesparender und
schneller lösen können sie nutzen eine
weitere eigenschaft von elektronen sie
tragen nämlich nicht nur eine ladung
sondern sie haben auch einen
quantenmechanischen spin
das entspricht der drehung eines
kreisels also den drehimpuls und dieser
schwung hat eine richtung und dieser
spin also dieser schwung bestimmt die
richtung eines magnetfeldes denn
elektronen sind geladen und wie beim
elektromagneten erzeugt die bewegung der
ladung ein magnetfeld magnetisiert man
halt so ein eisenstück dann richtet man
den
der elektronen aus und genau das macht
sich die spintronik zunutze spricht bei
der elektronik geht es um die ladung bei
der spintronik um den spin die
ausrichtung der elektronen und statt
einer ladung also plus oder minus an
oder aus 0 oder 1 besagt jetzt der spin
ob es sich um eine null oder eins
handelt bei der spintronik werden kleine
zylinder in nanogröße verwendet sie
haben einen durchmesser von zehn
millionstel millimetern dabei liegen in
den zylinder zwei magnetischen schichten
übereinander
sie sind durch eine extrem dünne schicht
getrennt elektronen können jetzt von der
einen in die andere schicht übertreten
das geht leicht wenn die magnetisierung
gleich ist der beiden schichten damit
auch der spin in die gleiche richtung
zeigt und schwer wenn die beiden
schichten unterschiedlich magnetisiert
sind also die pole in unterschiedliche
richtung weisen so können ganz einfach
informationen gespeichert werden 1 ist
ein hoher widerstand und 0 ein geringer
wert stand am stromfluss kann die
magnetische orientierung der
nanoröhrchen abgelesen werden hier aus
kann man jetzt ships bauen die sich wie
frei programmierbare prozessoren
verhalten
die nanoröhrchen bilden einen prozessor
der durch die nanoröhrchen jetzt
programmierbar ist die nanoröhrchen
bilden dabei die neuronen und die
übertritte der elektronen von der einen
in die andere schicht sind die
verbindung die synapsen in ihrem
übergängen ist das programm codiert und
wird jetzt also ein algorithmus auf
einen solchen chip programmiert
speichern die synapsen die richtigen
werte ab um die gestellte aufgabe
korrekt abzuwickeln das programm ist
dann fest auf dem chip quasi eingebrannt
in der modernen elektronik kennen wir
das als e tron
es ist ein chip auf dem programm fest
eingebrannt wird also es muss nicht erst
von der festplatte oder der sd-karte
oder sonst ein speichermedium geladen
werden es ist direkt im prozessor drin
nur hier bei der spintronik kann das
programm jederzeit wieder gelöscht
werden und neu programmiert werden im
gegensatz zur heutigen prozessoren die
für zahlreiche aufgaben geeignet sind
und programmabläufe dementsprechend
kompliziert sind werden diese spintronik
prozessoren immer wieder auf die neue
aufgabe optimiert ein solcher chip
könnte heute für 3d rendering optimiert
sein und morgen perfekt gesichter
erkennen jedes mal
besonders energieeffizient und schnell
und im gegensatz zu einem heutigen
prozessor muss nichts geladen und dann
eben ausgeführt werden es ist eben alles
bereits im prozessor der dann hoch
effizient arbeiten kann allerdings
müssen bei diesen neuro morgen ships wie
sie genannt werden die programme vorher
wie beim auf den chip geschrieben werden
das system kann es nicht selbst was dann
ein unglaublicher fortschritt wäre
dennoch muss die k also das programm was
dann auf dem chip ausgeführt wird auf
herkömmlichen rechnern trainiert werden
das geschieht mit einer feder
rückführung spricht der algorithmus der
kadi algorithmus muss erst lernen was
richtig und was falsch ist allerdings
sind forschung auch hier sicher diese
trainingsphase auch auf diesen chips
laufen zu lassen was bedeuten würde dass
hier eine autarke selbstlernende
künstliche intelligenz erschaffen würde
das wäre ein absoluter meilenstein für
manche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler ein absoluter traum für
andere ein alptraum
die französische wissenschaftlerin
yumiko je und ihr kollege demian krems
haben erste versuche mit neuro morgen
chips durchgeführt und die ergebnisse
sind absolut faszinierend
zusammengefasst es funktioniert sie
nutzt nur einen übergang zwischen zwei
schichten in einem nanoröhrchen und
konnten allerdings damit 400 neuronen
simulieren indem sie die aufgaben
nacheinander abarbeiten sie trainierten
ihr system mit einem herkömmlichen
computer und es machte seine arbeit
absolut perfekt die aufgabe die
erkennung von gesprochenen zahlen und
setzen dieses super einfaches system war
in der lage 99,6 prozent aller zahlen zu
erkennen die achtung ihr vorher
unbekannte stimmen aussprachen
jetzt stehen systeme in größerem maßstab
auf dem plan was könnte ein solches
system wenn es über millionen solcher
nanoröhrchen verfügen würde ein solches
system wäre absolut perfekt für
künstliche intelligenz nicht nur dass
das system in jedem bereich in der
passenden taktung arbeiten könnte diesen
euro hoffen können neuronen auch
synchronisieren und damit ergebnisse
gewichten sprich diese neuartige bauart
wäre ein quantensprung für die
künstliche intelligenz und der liegt
nicht wie praxistauglichkeit
quantencomputer in mehr oder weniger
weiter ferne sondern diese
systeme können hier und heute gebaut
werden ein solches thema zeig mir wieder
mal in welch aufregende zeiten wir leben
der technologische wandel wird immer
schneller schneller
darum geht es übrigens auch in meinem
neuen buch per aufzug in den weltraum
um die chancen und gefahren die uns
schon in der nahen zukunft erwarten also
draufklicken besorgen und lesen ihr habt
ja jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zeit
bis dann bleibt dran